mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
ein mensch kommt auf den welt und wir
sind berührt doch eine geburt ist auch
ein archaischer und der respekt einflößt
für sicherheit dass sich gefühle ist für
viele bedeutet sicherheit die
medizinische versorgung im spital
doch zunehmend entscheiden sich frauen
heute wieder für eine schwangerschaft
betreuung durch die hebamme und auch
eine ausstellung im bregenzerwald
beschäftigt sich mit der geburt und
zeigt eine geburtshöhle geborgenheit
vermitteln soll
kulturplatz über eine sehr persönliche
entscheidung
[Musik]
ein kind zur welt bringen das ist und
bleibt ein archaischer akt aber die
geburt das ist auch ein
gesellschaftliches jahr sogar ein
politisches thema entscheide ich als
frau selbst wie ich gewähren will suche
ich mir dafür die hebamme meines
vertrauens oder begebe ich mich in
erster linie in die hände von ärzten
um diese frage geht es bei uns heute um
das uhr weibliche thema der geburt und
zwar hier in matera geburtshaus in basel
wir kommen auf den platz
[Musik]
die allermeisten menschen in der schweiz
kommen im krankenhaus zur welt unter der
leitung von ärzten
doch immer mehr gibt es auch die
hebammen geleitete geburt in
geburtshäusern oder als hausgeburt das
heißt es gibt eine klare entwicklung weg
von der geburt aus rein medizinisches
thema hinzu geburt aus intimes ereignis
das am besten in geborgenheit
stattfinden soll
wo liegen hier die chancen und risiken
das schauen wir uns an
[Musik]
angelika zwerger sie haben ihre tochter
vor 13 monaten hier geboren was gab den
ausschlag für das geburtshaus ich habe
einen ort gesucht wo ich mich wohl und
sicher fühlen und geborgen
und das war dann eine bauchentscheidung
die für mich immer noch stimmt viele
sagen auch sicher dann ist man doch im
später im krankenhaus
ja das kam für mich eigentlich nie
infrage das krankenhaus besonders weil
ich weil ich gemerkt habe wie wie ich
mich hier sicher fühle eben durch die
begleitung der hebammen von anfang an
ich wusste dass das gras und dass das
krankenhaus gleich hier um die ecke ist
und das ziemlich jeder zeit hinbringen
können und die hero man habe mir immer
gesagt wir lassen es nicht darauf
ankommen sie geben heute ein konzert
hier an diesem ort im geburtshaus sie
nachher auch mit dabei
[Musik]
im bregenzerwald geschieht seit einiger
zeit viel weg weisen dass in sachen
architektur
da ist es kein wunder dass es dort nun
auch ein ganz und gar außergewöhnliches
geburtshaus gibt zu sehen in einer
ausstellung die sich ganz dem thema
geburt widmen
das wunder des lebens ein kind wächst im
mutterland
er blickt schließlich das licht der welt
eine ausstellung im österreichischen
frauenmuseum hittisau widmet sich jetzt
diesem thema geburt kultur vom gebären
und geboren werden gezeigt für
zeitgenössische kunst aber auch über die
geschichte der geburt erfährt man
einiges
so werden unter anderem auch alte
rollenmuster hinterfragt erklärt die
direktorin des frauenmuseums das heißt
diese geburtshilfe die in frauenhand
wahl ist irgendwann mit dem beginn der
neuzeit zu einem technisch medizinischen
vorgang geworden und dies zunehmend
wirklich zu einem männlichen domäne
geworden und das war auch ein teil den
wir hier wirklich anschauen wollten in
der ausstellung ausstellung wir
präsentieren zum beispiel hebammen die
sich sehr eingesetzt haben dafür dass
dieses hebammen wissen dieses tradierte
wissen auch wirklich erhalten bleibt und
weiter gegeben wird
der medizinische fortschritt und die
entdeckung der hygiene und 1840 ließen
die sterblichkeitsrate bei gebärenden
deutlich sinken
die geburt war bis ins frühe 20
jahrhundert jedoch noch von traditionen
und riten geprägt die bis zur
gewaltanwendung bei schwangeren gingen
es war sehr sehr lange üblich eigentlich
bisschen das zwanzigste jahrhundert
hinein kinder die gedroht haben bei der
geburt zu sterben im mutterleib zu
taufen
jetzt ist auf der einen seite ein ritus
um ein kind in eine gemeinschaft
aufzunehmen und gleichzeitig kann das
natürlich pervertiert werden indem
dieser form von kontrolle und von
übergriff passiert mit dieser spritze
die durch die bauchdecke geführt worden
ist hat man auf alle fälle in kauf
genommen andere organe zu treffen und es
gab auch wirklich theologische
diskussion darüber ob denn die taufe
gültig sein wenn sie nicht den kopf oder
zum beispiel einen fuß oder anderer
organe trifft und man ist zum schluss
gekommen ja sie ist gültig die
nationalsozialisten machten wird dazu
gewehre rinnen der nation
die frau wurde auf ihre rolle in der
familie und im haushalt reduziert
sie sollte ihre schlaf zu hause führen
indem sie kinder kriegt und heute auch
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wird
der weibliche körper noch in den dienst
eines ideals gestellt manche schwören
auf den kaiserschnitt ohne medizinische
notwendigkeit keep your life channel
honeymoon fresh heißt es im körper
fixierten amerika also kaiserschnitt ist
natürlich eine operation die viele viele
leben gerettet hat das wissen wir und
das ist gut so gleichzeitig erleben wäre
natürlich ein trend hin zum wunsch
kaiserschnitt der wirklich schon sehr
sehr über worden dieses gibt länder wie
brasilien wo mehr als 60 prozent der
kinder per kaiserschnitt entbunden
werden und da muss man sich natürlich
auch fragen was für vor
wertvorstellungen stehen dahinter was
für ein verständnis vom körper steht
dahinter hierzulande wollen wieder mehr
frauen eine natürliche geburt
wollen nachdem man sicherheit jahrelang
nur in der schulmedizin zu finden
glaubte in einem vertrauten umfeld
gebären im garten des frauenmuseums
steht seit neuestem ein modell das
diesem wunsch nachkommen soll manca der
ist architektin und angehende hebammen
sie hat den raum für geburt uns sinne
entwickelt geburts heime wurden von der
architektur bislang etwas vernachlässigt
die geburt hat eingang gefunden in der
geburtsmedizin aus architektonischer
sicht wurde das thema einfach nicht
behandelt bis dato es in der sicherheits
fokussiert wenn es um die geburt geht
aber was gibt denn sicherheit und was
gibt schutz und da kann man schon
beginnen zu diskutieren und zu um zu
hinterfragen sicheres gebären näher bei
sich selbst aber abseits von
funktionalen kreißsälen ganz ohne
schulmedizin geht das nicht das weiß
auch an qadir der geburtsraum ist hier
deswegen nur ein prototyp
später soll er einmal im kontext zu
einem nahe gelegenen spital stehen wo im
notfall reagiert werden kann
der geburtsraum versteht sich als
ergänzung es gibt ja kein bild es ist
eine fläche die bedient werden kann also
damit kann zum beispiel hier sein oder
auch hier oben und partnerin oder
partner können auch der oberen fläche
sein
und dann gibt es weitere hilfen also zum
beispiel dieses tuch an dem man sich
dran hängen kann so dass das wird ganz
oft verwendet in der in der geburtshilfe
und dann gibt es da auch griffe an dem
er sich anhängen kann einfach um
verschiedene positionen auszuprobieren
die das gebären erleichtern sollen
denn meine frau arbeitet bei der geburt
mit der schwerkraft die unterstützt
darum lässt das kind nach unten zu
bringen
der raum für geburt und sinne besteht
aus lehmziegeln
die sorgen nicht nur für ein angenehmes
raumklima sondern haben auch so anka tür
einen regulierenden einfluss auf das
nervensystem
eigentlich braucht es für eine geburt
dieselbe atmosphäre wie für einen
sexuellen akt und alles was unseren
parasympathikus unsere entspannung
anregt das ist gut für die geburt das
kuratorenteam und anke dürr möchten mit
dieser geburtshöhle ein zeichen setzen
zum denken anregen um neben der
optimierten geburtsmedizin wie sie heute
praktiziert wird mehr
auswahlmöglichkeiten für gebärende zu
schaffen
[Musik]
und da sehen wir jetzt ihr geburts markt
eher und zwar mit der leitende hebamme
mit dem aktuell in afrika sieht 15
jahren stiegen die zahlen von der
hebamme geleitete gebuchte der schweiz
stark auf was führen sie das zurück
ich glaube es sind wir zwar respekt
einer sitzt glaube ich dass frauen sich
mehr über das buch ist wirklich zum gut
tue der prozess durch wofür jeder glaube
ich die grenze zwischen leben und andere
sitz ist es einfach so dass sie die
stelle ganz viel oder flac sport wird
mit der neue jetta das heißt auch immer
weniger hebammen im spital pro frau
wirklich an der freyung mit
organisations zur verfügung steht vor
der geburt hat viele leute speck die
einst sogar angst und wähle dann
sicherheit im spital
was spricht für das geburtshaus trotz
deiner sicherheitsgedanken wie china
lügt
ich glaube sicherheit sich erfüllen ist
für alle
die oberste priorität die frage was
bedeutet sicherheit und das ist sehr
individuell
die andere bedeutet sicherheit
apparatemedizin in allernächster nähe
und für die anderen bedeutet sicherheit
in erster linie geborgenheit und
intimität
also ich mit ihm einig es gibt keine
richtige erzgebirger kosovo für frauen
zutrifft stimmt wenn sie sämtliche
informationen hätten sie braucht das
rahmenplan kaiserschnitt sie ohne grund
wird das trauma wo sich jetzt für die
geburt im geburtshaus entscheidet die
ihr merken ganz klar damit ich
bestmöglich kg wäre damit ich alles
damit ich mich ganz mich auf sein um
mich dann stelle war das kind von mir
fordert komplette öffnung physisch
psychisch national brauche ich schon
direkt und auch nicht kennen
das heißt sie lernen natürlich die
schwangere viel vor der geburt kann das
erste beziehung und nicht erst unter der
gebucht
darüber wenn sie schon mal geboren wie
ich stoße sie was ich weiß nicht wie
leute ist das jetzt hier lernen die
partner keine geschichte findet alle
habt ihr die flugleitstelle und
eigentlich jetzt rasch mit schwarzem
wenn wir den zu gebote mit dennis
vertrauensverhältnis
[Musik]
da sehen wir jetzt immer öfter in der
c30 mutter und kind erhole und da platz
für die ganze familie verschüchtert die
zum zusammenwachsen erst sabrina jobs
für sie gebetet im februar dauer ihres
zweite kind wie es zum entscheid hohes
gebot ist also wichtig ist grund für
mich echt verbindung zu der hebamme
durch jetzt im fall von mattea
geburtshelfer für die zuständig sind sie
begleitet die wahl schwangerschaft und
man lernt sich kennen bald dafür bin ich
auf sie lernt die kennen lernt aus
ungeborenen kind kennen und das ist für
mich der wichtigste grund wie sich im
geburtshaus peter jetzt geht es mit
komplikationen während der geburt
angebots magdalena wie ist das ist mal
ist man voraus im operationssaal müssten
jetzt mit sehr guter standort für das
ist das ab und telefonisch um hilfe rief
und seine besucher die folge werde ich
ziemlich politischen background ist
satire stand bislang im operationssaal
wie wäre es für sie wenn sie da startet
im geburtshaus mit der geburt und dann
geht siegen dann dringen der grund dass
sie müssten wachsen stellt sich auf wie
sie das ja also ich hab das schon mal ab
zu über meine erste geburt im
geburtshaus karabiner unis erwachsene
ins spital ist aber alles gut gelaufen
folgende jetzt ruft das wieder zu
probieren aber gab es schon wichtig dass
man weiß man hat die sicherheit falls
jetzt wirklich schlimmes passieren dass
man ihre zeit verwachsen beschlüsse dir
dann komplikationen größtmöglich muss
also nicht alles vorbei vor der aufnahme
behauptung eine frau dafür tagebau es
gibt ganz klare indikation ist kindlich
muss richtig linke also mit dem kopf
nach unten führt zwilling sicher für
geboten
frau darf nicht
die schwere grunderkrankung haben noch
einmal gebucht wird nicht gut laufen
das thema geburt polarisiert enorm zum
schluss sein der alle einfach gut
gebucht ich glaube das thema bewegt
einfach jeder mensch irgendwo weil es
von einer weniger thema im leben nicht
alles in der hand hat die totale
sicherheit geht es mit einem großen
thema wir stark und sterben nicht und
der sängerin im grün
märz ist viel in der hand und das
berührt ein motor und ritzen aussagen
und es später der geburtsort geradezu
eine große rolle
das hat das thema insel das muss nicht
wieder handeln
danke für das gespräch und alles wäre
für heute geboten
[Musik]
da ist das kind erst auf der welt spürt
es bald zum allerersten mal stoff auf
seiner haut und das ganze leben lang
lassen wir wenig so oft an unseren wie
die kleider
dementsprechend viele haben wir auch
davon mich eingeschlossen
aber auch hier ist ein bewusstwerdung
prozess in gang weniger ist mehr das
wiederum ist ein echtes problem für die
modeindustrie chanel wollte das weltall
erobert das waren noch zeiten
die mode feierte sich selbst unbekümmert
und verschwenderisch und jetzt mit
corona an dem verkürzten herbstschau new
york gab es nur kleine happenings kaum
publikum große marken zeigten überhaupt
keine kollektionen und kunstvolle videos
statt echte chance die london fashion
week fand hauptsächlich digital stadt
sieht gut aus täuscht aber nicht darüber
hinweg dass die mode in der krise steckt
das merkt wer an der handelstagen des
trend forschungsinstituts gdl teilnimmt
branchenvertreter höheren deiner thomas
zu die bestseller autorin schreibt seit
jahren über die probleme in der
modeindustrie und stellt dieser ein
miserables zeugnis aus ob luxus segment
oder fast fashion spielt dabei keine
rolle
verändert sich die fashion industrie
nicht radikal wird der co2 ausstoß in
den nächsten zehn jahren um 50 prozent
steigen
besagt ein bericht der uno das ist
wachstum das ist das problem
viele unternehmen haben grüne
initiativen innerhalb ihrer firma auch
gehring der luxuskonzern mit marken wie
gucci oder salon
die wollen mit ihrer grünen initiative
den carbon ausstoß senken
das bringt nicht viel das ist ein
bisschen so wie wenn sie auf der
sinkenden titanic noch die stühle neu
arrangieren sie nennt in ihrem neuen
buch an verfälschen schier unglaubliche
zahlen zur mode und wie wir sie
konsumieren
120 milliarden kleidungsstücke werden
jedes jahr hergestellt jugendliche
kaufen heute fünfmal mehr kleidung als
ihre eltern ein kleidungsstück wird
heute im durchschnitt sieben mal
getragen
die modeindustrie ist für zehn prozent
des weltweiten co2 ausstoßes
verantwortlich und für 20 prozent der
globalen wasserverschmutzung im lockdown
haben wir weniger mode gekauft jetzt
schotten wir wieder aber weniger als
vorher und mehr online
unternehmensberatung rechnen mit 30
prozent weniger umsatz für 2020 für den
textil experten damit fällt hat sich das
system mode selbst in die knie gezwungen
corona haare da wie ein
brandbeschleuniger gewirkt die industrie
ist immer absatzkrise reihe die
konsumentinnen machen das ja auch nicht
bedingungslos mit sie kriegen ja schon
mit im grunde kriege ich alles auch im
rabatt oder irgendwo günstiger
eigentlich hat sich die industrie selbst
kannibalisiert sie hat sich ein system
geschaffen von permanenten sales und
jetzt wundert sie sich dass die
kundinnen irgendwie da auch irgendwo ja
nicht mehr so mitmachen wie sich die
industrie das 5
die konsumierenden haben umgedacht jetzt
müsste die modebranche nachziehen aber
wie
weder tally weijl noch vero moda oder
auch zara wolken stellung nehmen dafür
bezieht dries van noten stellung einer
der wichtigsten designer der gegenwart
seit 34 jahren im geschäft im mai
fordert er weniger kollektionen zu
zeigen weniger stücke zu produzieren
weniger hausverkäufe durchzuführen
über 600 filmen unterschreibenden
öffentlichen appell darunter große wie
dior oder schillernder mode machen meint
auch werte vermitteln
dafür steht sich sie zu belegen die
design himmel keine fashion sondern
bekleidung anbieten seit 1972 ihre
stücke sind nicht trendy sondern
überdauern die saison
das muss man sich leisten können und vor
allem wollen
das neue krieg und erhalte bezieht
vorfreude vorfreude sparen müsse dafür
und dann halt länger halten und dann
berichtet weiß ich sie zu überlaufen
heute schon die kinder und enkelkinder
der ersten kunden generation ein
potenzial für mehr nachhaltigkeit ortet
sie vor allem bei der frauenmode
diese so ihr plädoyer müsse sich mehr
der herrenmode angleichen und es geht
also wie häufig und ich find das könnte
mir durchaus sein können als frauen
ich finde es ein rückschritt war mir
heute plötzlich tot und süßigkeiten
twitter prozent
kleidung und ihre herstellungsweisen für
die zukunft denken
das geschieht am institut mode design
der fachhochschule in basel stelle mayer
steht kurz vor ihrem masterabschluss sie
entwickelt einen modularen anzug der
sich in bis zu acht stücke aufteilen
lässt die einzelteile wie hermel oder
kragen können dann per schnur
zusammengebracht werden
mach jetzt extrem leichte westens die
man komplett auseinander kleistern kann
so dass man eigentlich ja dass man
eigentlich sehr viel mehr von einem
western hat dass man den anpassen kann
dass man ihn noch länger behält dass man
nicht mit seinem partner mit seinem
bruder mit seiner mutter teilen kann das
ist man mehr spielraum hat ihre mit
studierenden aus dem bachelor sind da
deutlich radikaler unterwegs während
einer schulinternen diskussion person
wird klar
secondhand und recycling ließ zwar das
gebot der stunde aber nicht konsequent
genug
maria rodriguez hat sich auf der suche
nach nachhaltigkeit mit strick und
tracht beschäftigt ihre erkenntnis
nachhaltig ist nur wenn sie nichts
produziert punkt will egal wie
nachhaltig sich nicht nachhaltig machen
es nie perfekt machen
darauf setzte dass italien als ich noch
am ort produzieren wenn das problem
liegt das profil zu produzieren und das
ist viel zu viel konsumiert
es geht darum weniger zu konsumieren und
zu produzieren star-designerin vivienne
westwood tut das schon und hat ihr label
und 37 prozent verkleinert
auch weniger schick weniger wachstum in
einer branche mit zweifelhaften ruf wenn
corona das beschleunigt hat das durchaus
reizvoll in zürich läuft aktuell das
filmfest sie war das erinnert mich daran
was in filmen geburtsszene häufig so
plakativ dargestellt sind
das einem dabei die haare zu berge
stehen aber egal unser kulturminister
albers er liebt das szenische schaffen
ganz im speziellen das einheimische und
nun wähler wieder einem neuen gesetz
dafür sorgen dass kino konkurrenten wie
netflix und co auch einen beitrag
leisten an die filmförderung dieses
gesetz allerdings ist nicht ganz einfach
um es auf die welt zu bringen es gibt
einige schwierigkeiten bei der
geburtsvorbereitung sie feiern sich
ihre werke und corona resistenz publikum
säumte das festival
hinter den kulissen aber treibt ein
anderes thema die szene um die so
genannte lex netflix
sie soll internationale streaming
anbieter zur kasse bitten
denn wer hier produkte verkauft soll
auch steuern zahlen so filmproduzent
michael steiger im grundsatz des
investitions pflicht wenn es schon vom
radio f 16 jets kenne das heißt wie
damals arterial befahren strufe gaudi
kassiert und der mexikaner hugo mache
schweiz die schweizer bis zur rückgabe
von dem musizieren es nur arbeitsplatz
in deutschland wo arbeitsplätze schweiz
der bundesrat schlug vier prozent der
hiesigen einnahmen von netflix und co
vor der nationalrat hat den anteil auf 1
prozent reduziert auch aus furcht die
plattformen erhöhten sonst die
abogebühren brächte dem schweizer film
jährlich wohl rund zwei millionen
franken was gerade einmal dem budget
einer tatort folge entspricht zum
vergleich nationaler geldgeber wie die
srg mit 32 5 millionen oder der teleclub
nachfolger blu mit geschätzt einer
million engagieren sich deutlich stärker
müssten fortan aber ebenfalls nur noch
ein prozent zwingend entrichten
da vergeht ihr das lachen bettina oberli
regisseurin des eröffnungsfilms am
festival in zürich effekt wo der
filmbranche sowie schade dass man
wirklich muss sage lieber den guard
referenten aus die hand der neue
direktor des zff glaubt hingegen dass
die freiwilligen und obligatorischen
abgaben gesamthaft zunehmen werden
allein die es ag hat ihren jahresbeitrag
zuletzt um fünf millionen erhöht jede
frau den kreislauf und die spurte und
insofern ist das bessere ausnützung der
freunde im winter wird sich der
ständerat mit der gesetzesvorlage
beschäftigen fernab von bundes bern
kennen bereits zahlreiche staaten solche
abgaben sie legen oft klar über einem
prozent doch es fragt sich wie viel
autonomie das kostet viel schneller wird
jetzt eine künstlerische positionen
wir kommen der wahrheit oder das soll
galt generieren zuschauer generieren
maschine kathy kelly rutherford besitze
ich nicht dass sie kreativprozess große
krise sondern sie suche auf gut die
umsetzung gut die time was sie wusste
die funktionieren und verdammt ich mir
schon vorstellen dass sehr schnellen
impuls kg und müssen auch produzieren wo
es natürlich viel schneller geht aus dem
film muss über verschiedene gefördert
instanzen probiert finanzieren wo unter
umstadt 12 austria kommen mit netflix
fehler innerhalb von einem jahr das
projekt zu realisieren umsätze und das
findet natürlich große fordern
michael steiger spricht aus erfahrung
dank der von ihm produzierten komödie
wolkenbruch über einen juden aus
orthodoxer familie der sich gegen
religiöse konventionen auflehnt
wie ist der bisher einzige schweizer
film bei netflix wieso frauen ist wie
man selbst
dazu kommen erster netflix produktionen
mit schweizer schauspielerinnen wie luna
wieder in bio heckels die deutsche serie
zum thema gentherapie erhält nun eine
zweite staffel inspiration für die
hiesige szene
also ich glaube ich noch nie mehr
sorgfalt die drehbuchentwicklung
investieren
häufig ist problem wie der bürger
während gut die handwerker im schweizer
film production values sind immer besser
wo das heißt die film gesehen immer
attraktiv russ und wo ich dann auch die
handlungsbedarf orte ist natürlich dann
im marketing und ethisches zusammengang
mit netflix natürlich spannend weil hier
sehr viel know-how hand und wüssten wie
man den film an mann und frau bringen um
im besten licht zu erscheinen gilt für
das heimische schaffen also gleich
mehrfach ort dass er unsere sendung aus
dem geburtshaus mathea in basel und hier
ist auch klar geworden wie eine frau ihr
kind gebären möchte das ist und bleibt
eine sehr intime entscheidung gleich
nach uns geht's weiter 51 mit einer
spezialsendung vom zurich film festival
nächste woche übernimmt hier meine
kollegin nina brunner mit der frage wie
stark sind people of colour in der
schweizer kulturszene vertreten ja und
jetzt jetzt dürfen wir noch ein ganz
frisch geborenes menschlein anschauen
die ein tage alte lilian küsters bald
wieder
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos